démarrée dans la maison aujourd'hui
éducateur zenfants que joue la comédie
andy fait l'acteur pour la première fois
devant l'objectif des étudiants de
troisième année de l'école de cinéma
troisième dans le film le jeune enfant
et noah a eu une grosse débauche un
petit peu la cites un garçon en fait qui
va déménager
et il n'aura pas le temps de dire au
revoir à ses amis donc bah il ya un peu
triste et à la fin les élèves de sa
classe se sauve de l'école pour venir
lui dire au revoir
c est non parce que ça leur permet de
voir un petit peu ce qui se fait en
termes de l'audiovisuel etc
et puis surtout sur des grandes échelles
comme ça parce que c'est vraiment un
tournage de film donc s'est plaint des
étoiles dans les yeux des enfants et
c'est ce que c'est pour ça qu'on fait ce
boulot c'est pour ça qu'on cherche à et
honnêtement il voit aussi l'envers du
décor donc c'est génial
le village d'enfants sert de décor au
court métrage dans la vraie vie chaque
pavillon abrite six enfants et un
éducateur familiale dans le cadre de la
protection de l'enfance
particularité ici on accueille des
fratries dans le village on est 57
enfants il y a cinq enfants donc qui
participent qui ont les rôles principaux
et du coup il va y avoir des figurants
pour faire une école enfin pour faire
une classe d'élèves
il existe en france 15 villages comme
celui ci il y aura donc quinze courts
métrages et un festival pour récompenser
le meilleur
nous aurons l'occasion de remettre deux
prix le 27 mai au grand rex à paris on
project râler les quinze courts métrages
de loin un parterre de personnalités
avec 650 personnes qui seront invitées
dont les enfants
bien évidemment les éducateurs et à
partir du 15 avril les internautes
pourront voter pour déterminer le prix
du public
la première récompense c'est déjà le
sourire des enfants
le reportage est terminée coupez